what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel this is a
continuation of my morning thoughts
so
today i'm going to talk about
hypocrisy
okay so
i found that
the people that get the maddest at my
comments okay
the most the most angry it's never
okay i had the one friend one close
friend
that was upset with me over my
leave your fat wife comments
um
and okay but outside of that like most
of my close good friends
sorry they're like get that bag sis
do what you gotta do right and i don't
say should i don't believe i might take
a clip to make it seem
more extreme than it really is
but
everything i say like i believe
opinions change right but anyways what i
found
is the people that get mad at me are
like these weird friend of friends where
i kind of know them we're kind of
friendly over the years
i see them from time to time
at family functions or
like friends from you know whatever it
is right and they're the ones
messaging my mom even though i'm 25.
okay stop stop messaging my mother
it's not cool it's not okay
then
they get the madness and one in
particular
left
a
long ass comment on my instagram just
talking about how terrible that was and
she's like i'm pregnant
what if i get fat i'm like lady
and the crazy thing is these women they
love drama they love like they are so
excited to have something to talk about
they're like bored
in this little town
and they're so excited thing to have so
excited to have something to talk about
and because i'm exciting and i'm
interesting just happens to be me
not my fault not my problem
shoe fits not my problem not my fault
anyways
sorry i'm kind of tired these are a
little all over the place but
this girl is so funny because
this girl was the biggest she's like a
nurse right she was the biggest preacher
about cobit cove and coca-cola and she
was the [ __ ] like
always arguing with people about coven
like
get vaccinated you're like she would
have these long-ass dramatic-ass
facebook post she looks so dumb
about kovid right
and this woman this woman this is the
same woman
that came to a bachelorette party
and gave us all coven
and then magically okay she she didn't
know she had been in contact with
someone that had covet okay that's what
she said she didn't know until
magically at the end of the bachelorette
party how
how crazy is that that you decide to get
tested after and that's what i'm saying
like half the people okay
that
are in your comment section complaining
about [ __ ]
and half the people
that
are being dramatic i promise you are the
biggest hypocrites if i know anyone in
real life
that like comments
posts about this [ __ ]
in like an angry way you know the
difference there's a difference between
discussion
and
just being a [ __ ]
and
i just know it when i see it so
yeah that's my only point is that these
people i swear to god biggest hypocrites
you will ever meet in your life
oh my god so funny i needed to share
that okay i'm gonna i might make another
we'll see if i think of one
stop